[Music]
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry hanging out with cousin Paige
Malibu edition I'm here in beautiful
where are we Malibu we're in Malibu
California with my cousin Paige and
she's going to read off some of the
questions that people have been giving
me on u2 about evolution so this is 113
questions about evolution malibu edition
so yeah first question so since we're at
the beach why I will so big why are
whales so big whales our last time I
checked I might have found dinosaurs
that are bigger now but last time I
checked the blue whale was the largest
animal that we have ever known in the
fossil record ever to live on the face
of the earth but not all whales are
large right so dolphins and porpoises
are also considered whales but they're
tiny right some of them are really small
but then there are no fish that even
come close to the blue whale so the
whales really are huge and the reason
for that is oxygen a lot of people think
it's kind of a disadvantage that whales
breathe air because they can possibly
drowns you know you have you run the
risk of dying by just you know doing
your thing living in the water but
having lungs and being able to breathe
air is a huge advantage over breathing
water because there's very little oxygen
dissolved into water so the largest fish
that exists would probably be the it's
the whale shark and if you ever watched
them they have to constantly be swimming
the other mouths open they have these
huge gills like most of their body is
gills pretty much and if they stopped or
slowed down too much
they'll actually die of suffocation so
they have to constantly swim and
constantly have their mouths open
whereas whales they've got those lungs
they can just take a nice deep breath of
air so it's a combination of gravity not
really affecting them because they float
combined with the fact that they can get
so much good air that has allowed them
to develop such huge body sizes like
evolution just had more
play with as far as size goes so that's
why whales are bigger than fish next
question
you